You all know that.
I don't think Donald Trump is a good president.
I don't think he's an honest person.
I don't think he's competent.
I believe he's way in over his head.
He's the worst president I've personally lived
through.
But I also hope, you know, that when Trump
or anyone does the right thing, I'm not afraid
to say it.
And in some small ways, Donald Trump did some
good things yesterday while also doing many,
many bad things during his coronavirus press
conference and later on Twitter.
Trump gave what for him again for him was
his most presidential statement and briefing
on coronavirus and maybe on anything since
the start of his presidency, because Trump
came out and he didn't immediately brag uncontrollably
about how great his response has been.
He was initially sober and quite frankly,
scared looking and saying we need to take
some serious precautions in outlining a list
of those behavior changes that need to happen.
He actually looked like when I say scared,
he looked like he understood the gravity of
the situation.
And he admitted Corona virus is not under
control.
New guidelines recommended by Trump yesterday.
Home school.
All kids don't go to bars.
Don't go to restaurants.
No gatherings of more than 10 people.
Okay.
No idea whether state governors will put those
policies into action.
But we have to start getting through to the
Trump ists who are acting like nothing is
going on, spreading the disease, going to
beaches, going to concerts and bragging about
it.
And that's why this matters.
Trump went on to say a whole bunch of crazy
stuff and lies and tweets and I'll tell you
about it.
But even Trump saying this matters because
this is just math, okay?
His RedState followers have not been taking
this seriously and they are preventing us
from limiting transmission.
They've been going to beaches and concerts
and parties and spreading the disease.
Here is Trump obviously lying about never
having previously said the virus was under
control.
But at least he is saying, no, the virus is
not under control.
And apologies about the tinny audio on this
clip.
Do you want to revisit that same you're experience
in this July, August 5?
I'm saying we are doing a very good job within
the confines of what we're dealing with.
We're doing a very good job.
There's been a there's been a tremendous amount
of the the way they're working together.
They're working hand-in-hand.
I think they're doing really a great job.
And from that standpoint, that's what I was
just saying.
It's under control right now.
Research meetings, she.
You're talking about the virus that's under
the control for any place in the world.
I think I read.
I didn't know second about what we're doing
is under control, but I'm not talking about
the virus.
So still some deception saying I never said
it was under control.
That's not true.
That's a lie.
He said it was under control many, many times.
But he's at least admitting it is not under
control.
Trump says the new guidelines might be necessary,
might be necessary until July or August.
That is mind blowingly inconceivable to tens
of millions of Americans.
But here is Trump laying out what he sees
as the worst case scenario.
Do you have any kind of estimate to if Americans
really were to band together and do what the
White House is suggesting?
How you could turn?
My favorite question all the time.
How many times entity?
I think I ask him that question every day.
And I speak to Deborah.
I speak to a lot of them.
I get the opinion.
So it seems to me that if we do a really good
job will not only hold the death down to a
level that is much lower than the other way.
Had we not done a good job, but people are
talking about July, August, something like
that.
So it could be right in that period of time
where I say wash, it washes through.
Other people don't like that term, but word
washes through this.
The new normal until I do the.
We'll see what happens.
But they think August.
Would be July could be longer than that.
But I've asked that question many, many times
now where he did go off the rails was reading
his response to the virus as a 10 out of 10.
And on a scale of one to ten, how would you
rate your response to this crisis?
A dreaded attempt.
I think we've done a great job.
Yeah, that that's crazy.
And so that's the the regular old Trump we
know coming out.
He also kept repeating.
Who could have imagined this a month ago?
Nobody imagined this could happen a month
ago.
That's not presidential and that's not honest.
We've been covering it for months and we weren't
even particularly early to the game.
We've all been warning for months that this
is exactly the situation that could develop
and it has.
And then also later in the day, Donald Trump
losing all presidential political capital
that he gained with the statement by tweeting
about the so-called Chinese virus, saying
the United States will be powerfully supporting
those industries like airlines and others
that are particularly affected by the Chinese
virus.
We will be stronger than ever before.
Chinese virus, of course, completely xenophobic
and discriminatory and counterproductive in
every way, particularly when now China actually
is not the epicenter nor the place with the
most active cases.
And they have it under control.
Completely meaningless statement.
And then again this morning, Cuomo wants all
states to be treated the same, but all states
aren't the same.
Some are being hit hard by the Chinese virus.
Some are being hit practically not at all.
New York is a very big hotspot where West
Virginia has thus far zero cases.
Andrew, keep politics out of it.
Of course, it is very political to rebrand
it.
The Chinese virus.
This is the same racist, xenophobic, blamed
China.
Chinese people's stuff.
And Trump clearly not able to remain a normal
person or remotely presidential for more than
a few minutes at the time.
Yesterday confirm that.
But I will take the small win where I can
get it.
Frump saying not under control.
Don't go to school, don't go to bars.
Don't congregate in groups of more than 10,
don't go to restaurants.
And it and this could last until July or August.
It's something that will hopefully influence
his followers.
Massachusetts is basically shut down in terms
of the restaurant industry, in terms of entertainment,
in terms of all of that stuff.
Gyms are shut down.
Individual restaurants, at least as far as
we know, aren't going to be bailed out like
the airlines and the cruise ship industry
and oil companies or anybody else.
And even if this goes on until only June,
the recovery time for some industries is potentially
going to be years long.
Many businesses are not going to return from
this, and that's horrible.
But we have to do what we have to do.
And that's why we're we're taking it so seriously
here